bonjour jean la capelle merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors à 6
peut-on un nouveau départ ou plutôt un
jeu de chaises musicales selon vous mais
je crois que lui dit parfaitement bien
c'est un jeu de chaises musicales auquel
nous assistons dans une équipe qui a
cumulé les échecs depuis trois ans
maintenant une équipe peu qui finalement
dans ton sort les quelques boulets avec
monsieur castaner et vous en parlez dans
votre sujet qui a géré la crise et j'ai
les zones de manière catastrophique qui
a lâché
les forces de l'ordre et qui d'ailleurs
elle même on finit également par lula
chez madame peloux paix qu'on sort
également du gouvernement qui pour
régler le point de justice avait décidé
de libérer les délinquants pendant la
crise sanitaire ou encore madame si bête
ndiaye qui faut le reconnaître a été
ridicule et accumulé les bourdes depuis
le début du quinquennat
voilà en contrepartie on fait un petit
peu de chemise on nomme monsieur dupont
moretti à la justice
7 ce militant notoire d'extrême gauche
qui est un exemple de démocratie puisque
il prône l'interdiction du rassemblement
national qui est quand même le propre
premier parti d'opposition en france
je laisse les français apprécié bien
évidemment celui qui souhaite le
rapatriement des jihadistes français
celui qui défend parfois les pires
criminels abdelkader meira en est un
exemple
voilà aujourd'hui ce à quoi on a six ou
encore monsieur darmanin le le comptable
du budget du gouvernement celui qui
court après la rentabilité qui courait
après les petites économies qui va être
en charge de l'intérieur et bien je suis
un petit peu inquiet pour les forces de
l'ordre qui elles ont besoin justement
de moyens financiers de soutien et de
reconnaissance
un gouvernement qui a la tâche de
relancer le pays dans les domaines de
l'économie du social mais aussi de
l'environnement à quoi peut-on
s'attendre selon vous mais écoutez je ne
sais pas moi je vais attendre bien
évidemment le discours de politique
générale du premier ministre ou des
mails battront puisqu'on ne sait pas
exactement qui sera premier ministre
je pense que le nouveau premier ministre
à lambres des macros qui reprend un peu
les rênes de l'exécutif
et c'est lui qui donne le cas c'est lui
qui a donné le cap depuis le début du
quinquennat et qui a donné un très
mauvais cas alors que vous le disiez on
a une relance économique a aujourd'hui à
entamer nous avons des problèmes sociaux
des problèmes économiques des
conséquences de la crise sanitaire qui
voit terrible qui sont devant nous des
traités de libre-échange qu'il faut
remettre en question aujourd'hui parce
qu'il tue des filières agricoles des
filières industrielles
nous avons une politique de
relocalisation que vous avez promis le
gouvernement puisque je crois tout on a
compris comment qui est de souveraineté
et que nous avons failli pendant cette
crise sanitaire que vendredi le faire
quel va être le cap qui va être donnée
dans ce domaine là nous avons une crise
démocratique va-t-on enfin instaurer un
mode de scrutin proportionnel
nous avons une crise fiscale avec le
pays champion du monde des impôts va
t'on baisser les impôts aujourd'hui pour
que les français retrouvent dubois
d'achat que les entreprises se
retrouvent à notre production qu'ils
soient compétitifs par rapport à
l'international nous avons une crise de
l'identité on la fuite dans la rue avec
des gens qui ne respectent plus l'état
nation qui respecte plus la république
ne respecte plus les forces de l'ordre
nous avons cette folle politique de
l'immigration
eh bien ce sont les enjeux bien sûr du
gouvernement sur lesquels rien n'a été
fait depuis le début du quinquennat et
sur lesquels je suis très inquiet mais
sur lesquels nous attendons
il ya des réponses très rapidement
justement pour revenir au discours de
politique générale il devait avoir lieu
en milieu de semaine par le premier
ministre jean castex on a appris que
finalement ça serait après
l'intervention du chef de l'état le 14
juillet ce que c'est un signe d'une
prise en main de la part d' emmanuel
macron oui je crois qu'il a toujours été
le poisson le chef du gouvernement
bon edouard philippe avait certainement
plus de charisme et monsieur gas tech et
castex sera dans l'ombre des murs de
notre compte on l'a compris il a trouvé
sans secrétaire général en quelque sorte
qu'il ne le fera pas droit sur ces deux
dernières années de quinquennat
quant au discours de politique générale
qui mêle macron va dessiner et l'écouté
il nous avait promis après le mode et
gilet jaune un grand virage l'écoutent
des français la transparence pendant la
crise à lithaire on a vu tout le
contraire on a vu des mensonges en a vu
que nous étions faibles que nous avons
pris des mauvaises décisions que nous
manquions de tous de masquer le test je
parie sur revenir et réécrire l'histoire
mais que va nous proposer mais elle
macron s'il continue à nous soumettre à
bruxelles à nous soumettre à la
politique la folle politique européiste
mais je crois que nous ne changerons pas
les problèmes aux défenses et si nous
continuons à bien sûr développer et
favoriser la politique des travailleurs
détachés
là aussi ça ne poserait ça ne favorisera
pas le l'emploi en france et 2 salles de
bain ça le ca ne sauvera pas le soignera
pas le chômage
voilà je suis très inquiet bien sûr
parce que même macron ne changera pas de
cap il a été élu sur la seconde d'idées
et bien écoutez il ne veux pas en
changer bien que les français soient
dans la rue qui se sont opposés à la
réforme des retraites
on nous dit que la réforme des retraites
il n'ya va revenir sur la table
l'écouté 6 est ce cela que va nous
annoncer mail macron je crains que les
français continuent d'exprimer leur
colère la rue en attendant impatiemment
le scrutin de mars 2022 pour qu'enfin
nous sur ce genre de politique et
l'équipe merci beaucoup aux gens la
capelle la voir réagir sur notre antenne
vous êtes député européen et délégué
national du rassemblement national